Well Bailey, I am very
impressed with you, I really am.
You seem like--
Thank you.
I really am.
You seem like a very funny
and witty and cool person.
You'd be the person, and
Sona back me up on this,
I would be talking to
Bailey a lot at the party.
Yes.
To the exclusion of other people
and we would both be trying to
out self-deprecate the other.
Yes.
And then afterwards it'd be
like, I really like Bailey.
Bailey seemed cool.
Yeah, yeah.
I would.
Yeah.
I appreciate that.
I mean, I think it's
probably the Irish-Catholic,
you know, Boston heritage in us both.
Oh, do you have heritage
back in Boston, do you think?
Well my dad's from Andover.
Oh God, that does it.
Oh no!
Yes, it's just in the blood.
Yeah, it's in the blood.
Yeah, we'll just one up each other
by going down on like,
how bad we are as people.
(laughs)
You might be related.
Probably are.
Yeah.
Probably are, you're
probably my third cousin
which makes your win illegal, by the way.
[Bailey] Oh.